foreign
weak and hungry after traveling for more
than a month
this is the second group of rohingya
refugees to land in Indonesia's Northern
ache province in recent days
on Wednesday local fishermen spotted a
boat that landed on the beach after a
further investigation we found out that
they are rohingya refugees
but there isn't much to go around the
local government in Buca tabai Village
is housing the refugees in a makeshift
Hall while they wait for food water and
Medicine
first of all on behalf of unhcr I would
like to give my highest appreciation to
the local government of Orchard for
allowing these refugees to land in North
Archie District next we'll coordinate
what we are going to do many of these
people started their Journeys in refugee
camps in Bangladesh where they've lived
since August 2017.
that's when myanmar's military began a
campaign of what the UN called textbook
ethnic cleansing to force the mainly
Muslim rohingya out of Western rakhine
State
it's difficult to survive in
Bangladesh's refugee camps I can't study
there our brothers can't get married
there it's difficult to arrange a
marriage for our sisters
the refugees say they want to start new
lives in Malaysia but those who survive
the long journey to get there face
detention Barbara and gopa Al Jazeera